[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en france24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares
dedicamos una parte de este programa a
la muerte de isabel segunda ya su
vínculo con áfrica aunque el
fallecimiento de la monarca ha provocado
un chorro de homenajes y elogios en todo
el continente
su deceso también suscitó a algunos
duros comentarios en las antiguas
colonias británicas
una fecha el 5 de septiembre fue el
aniversario el primer aniversario de la
caída del expresidente alpha condé en
guinea tras un golpe militar dirigido
por el coronel mamá de dumbo ya después
de un año en el poder hablamos del
balance de la junta militar y nos
dirigimos al parque nacional virunga en
el este de la república democrática del
congo una zona devastada por la guerra
allí los jóvenes de los pueblos de los
alrededores del parque son seleccionados
para ingresar en una escuela de fútbol
con la esperanza de convertirse en
futbolistas
en milicianos
siete décadas de reinado uno de los más
largos de la historia cuyo comienzo está
en
1952 en áfrica fue precisamente en kenia
donde la entonces princesa isabel se
convirtió en reina áfrica es un
continente que ocupó un lugar especial
en la vida de la soberana que falleció
el jueves 8 de septiembre en escocia y
que había jurado dedicar toda su vida a
las naciones de la commonwealth antes de
repasar los vínculos entre la reina y el
continente recordamos que la
commonwealth o mancomunidad de naciones
nació durante el período de
descolonización británica las antiguas
colonias y protectorados de reino unido
decidieron unirse prometiendo lealtad a
la corona británica el número de países
ha variado con el tiempo actualmente la
conforman en 56 estados estando la mayor
parte en el continente africano veamos
ahora un informe sobre los vínculos de
la reina con el continente
fue en kenia donde la princesa isabel se
despertó como reina el 6 de febrero de
1952 su padre el rey jorge sexto acababa
de morir de cáncer de pulmón en el este
del reino unido-
isabel segunda que se encontraba en el
continente africano en una gira por los
países de la commonwealth no se enteró
de la noticia hasta más de 24 horas
después de la muerte de su padre
mientras ella y su marido el duque de
edimburgo se tomaron un día libre de sus
obligaciones oficiales en un albergue de
observación de la fauna en un parque
nacional de kenia
la reina regreso a áfrica dos años
después eligió libia para su primer
viaje oficial al continente desde su
coronación en contra del consejo de
muchos políticos incluidos winston
churchill entonces líder de los
conservadores viajó en
1961 a la primera colonia africana que
se había independizado cuatro años antes
gana su visita a la capital ghanesa
akram fue recordada por el baile que
ofreció al presidente para africano come
en coma este gesto fue visto como una
señal de consideración por parte del
presidente ghanés en aquel momento el
objetivo de la reina era mantener el
mayor vínculo posible con esta antigua
colonia y limitar la influencia
soviética en el país
dieciocho años más tarde una visita a
áfrica volvió a ser noticia y fue
desalentada por el entorno de la monarca
especialmente por la primera ministra
margaret thatcher
isabel segunda insistió en ir a zambia
un país del sur de áfrica para la quinta
reunión de jefe de gobierno de la
commonwealth en un contexto de seguridad
muy tenso en un país fronterizo con
rhodesia del sur hoy zimbabwe en plena
guerra civil la reina presidió la
declaración de la firma de lusaka sobre
el racismo y la discriminación
un texto que estableció la igualdad
racial a nivel legal y condenó en la
parte de en sudáfrica y en sudáfrica
precisamente la monarca no pisó su suelo
hasta 1995 era la primera vez desde el
inicio de su reinado y la segunda desde
1947 durante su primera visita a
pronunció su primer discurso como
princesa heredera
pues eso
eres
y
48 años después el contexto político es
muy diferente en la parte aida terminado
y sudáfrica acaba de reincorporarse a la
commonwealth frente a nelson mandela en
la ciudad de puerto elisabeth la reina
exhortó a los jóvenes sudafricanos a
construir su nación también felicitó a
la población por haber realizado una
transición suave a la democracia
desde sudáfrica hasta nigeria y kenia
los homenajes a la reina han sido
numerosos pero también se han escuchado
voces críticas que recordaron los
trágicos episodios
expolios y represiones que marcaron la
historia del imperio colonial británico
del que era la reina es vista como
símbolo y heredera así lo demuestra la
extensa declaración emitida en sudáfrica
por el partido economic freedom fighters
del líder pan africano julius malema
no lloramos la muerte de la reina isabel
porque nos recuerda un periodo muy
trágico de la historia de nuestro país y
de áfrica reino unido bajo el liderazgo
de la familia real tomó el control
permanente del territorio en 1806 desde
ese momento los indígenas de este país
nunca han conocido la paz durante sus 70
años de reinado la reina nunca ha
reconocido las atrocidades que su
familia inflingió a los pueblos
indígenas que reinó unido- invadió en
todo el mundo en las redes sociales
algunos siglos dedicados a la muerte del
saber 2ª difundieron ampliamente este
comunicado así como imágenes de las
acciones cometidas por el ejército
británico en su antiguo imperio algunos
internautas africanos no dejaron de
recordar que pocos meses después de la
llegada al trono de la reina comenzó la
rebelión mau mau en kenia durante esta
insurrección anti colonial o
violentamente reprimida por los colonos
unos 100.000 kenianos murieron y 300.000
fueron encarcelados escuchemos algunas
de las reacciones al fallecimiento de
isabel 2a
recuerdo la lucha mao mao con mucha
amargura one
a bojan
yo era joven pero incluso siendo joven
un acuerdo que sufrimos mucho nuestros
padres nuestros tíos nuestros parientes
fueron detenidos o asesinados de wons
y
hay muchos recuerdos amargos pero creo
que la reina era demasiado joven porque
desde 1952 hasta el momento en que
terminó la guerra mau mau alrededor de
1957 ella estaba en el trono pero era
una dama muy muy joven
no podemos ignorar las cuestiones
relacionadas con el colonialismo la
reina se opuso a que los países
africanos en particular abandonaran a la
como nueva británica a que dejaran la
estructura colonialista así que creo que
no podemos ignorar todas esas cosas
tampoco las cuestiones relacionadas con
el apartheid en particular con la
complacencia de la monarquía en el
régimen del apartheid en sudáfrica
simplemente por el hecho de que soy
sudafricanas esas cosas creo son puntos
negros en los que respecta a su gobierno
nudos con sol cambiamos de tema para
hablar de la fecha aniversario del golpe
de estado en guinea fue el 5 de
septiembre de 2021 el entonces
presidente alpha condé fue destituido
por los militares en la capital del país
conakry el comité nacional de la
agrupación para el desarrollo el cmr de
nombre de la junta militar dirigida por
el coronel mamá de dumbo ya había tomado
el poder prometiendo una transición
rápida un año más tarde cuál es la
situación en el país la respuesta a la
vemos en este informe de sara sacó y
malik ya quite
en guinea el tema es tan polémico como
apasionante en un café de la capital
este grupo de amigos no se cansa de
debatir la trayectoria de los militares
que llegaron al poder hace un año apenas
entre el entusiasmo y la desilusión las
opiniones difieren el comité nacional de
la agrupación para el desarrollo de
guinea el cnt de vino y puso en marcha
un vasto proyecto de recuperación de los
dominios del estado ponerle ética a la
administración pública a través de la
creación del tribunal de represión de
los delitos económicos y financieros no
so más si desde el 5 de septiembre
estamos sentados nada se mueve así que
yo diría que la llegada del cnt de la
cabeza de nuestro país no se quiera peor
y a presentar un balance nos
arrepentimos junip a lieberman para vip
y lo sé tengo y cree acogido con alivio
general el coronel mamá de dumbo ya se
enfrenta ahora a muchas críticas
recientemente han estallado
manifestaciones convocadas por la
oposición y la sociedad civil
sus partidarios denuncian la
confiscación del poder la prohibición de
las manifestaciones la represión de los
opositores y la instrumentalización de
la justicia este político había la
llegada del comité nacional de
reconciliación y desarrollo ahora está
movilizando a sus tropas para protestar
contra la duración de la transición de
los 36 meses fueron impuestos al pueblo
de guinea mientras que la transición no
es un mandato la transición no debería
superar los 15 o 18 meses en resumen el
balance es negativo esto es para decir
que pretenden quedarse en el poder para
siempre pero el pueblo se opondrá a
ellos el gobierno por su parte defiende
su trayectoria y asegura que la
transición se desarrolla con normalidad
se han puesto en marcha una serie de
instituciones transitorias se ha
publicado una normativa existe un
consejo nacional de la transición que
actúa como asamblea nacional y una
administración que ahora está
ampliamente es politizada
un año después de la llegada de los
militares el diálogo político vuelve a
estar estancado en guinea una misión de
la cedeao para intentar desbloquear la
situación está en marcha vamos ahora a
la república democrática del congo para
presentarles una iniciativa
esperanzadora en el parque nacional de
virunga ubicado en el este del país y
famoso por sus guerrillas volcanes
jóvenes de las aldeas del parque están
siendo seleccionados para integrar una
nueva escuela de fútbol en una zona
devastada por la guerra la esperanza es
que se conviertan en futbolistas y no en
milicianos
dominar el balón para evitar la guerra
todos estos jóvenes que se están
formando tienen la esperanza de
convertirse en futbolistas proceden de
los pueblos de la región de virunga en
la república democrática del congo una
zona asolada por los grupos armados
los chicos han sido seleccionados para
formar parte de la nueva escuela de
fútbol creada por la administración del
parque nacional de virunga con el
objetivo de alejarlos del peligro de las
milicias
me gustaría recordarles el propósito por
el que vamos a entrenar aquí en primer
lugar queremos demostrar a todo el mundo
que también podemos vivir en paz y en
convivencia con particular la población
debe convivir bien con las guardas del
parque el estadio fue construido en
romang abu un pueblo de kivú al norte
que alberga la sede de la administración
del parque y una base militar aquí los
jóvenes nacidos en el caos y la
violencia son fácilmente reclutados por
los grupos armados
con esto no puedo tener la idea de
unirme a los grupos armados quiero estar
en lo que es legal quiero jugar al
fútbol y mi mayor sueño es llegar a ser
como cristiano ronaldo porque antes de
llegar a este nivel también empezó a
igual que yo
unos 50 jóvenes de entre 10 y 16 años
han sido seleccionados para la formación
el coordinador del proyecto los imagina
convertidos en futbolistas profesionales
viajando por el mundo lejos de la guerra
si el sueño de vivir algún día de su
pasión por el fútbol sigue siendo
hipotético para los iniciadores del
proyecto lo más importante es demostrar
que son posibles otros caminos distintos
a la guerra así termina este programa
gracias por acompañarnos la actualidad
sigue en france 24 y france 24 puntocom